yes it is it's like no air conditioning
are we missing anyone now
okay
little uh
so he's not imminent imminent he's just
all right well we'll call the meeting to
order again we are being live streamed
uh special requests to have that done
today
um the agenda is in front of you
certainly uh welcome to the meeting
and before we get into the elections I
thought it was appropriate do we go
around the room and introduce ourselves
and we'll start right over in the side
here and come right around
upstairs
I attended uh high school here uh called
foreign
as needed
thank you very much okay thank you good
afternoon my name is
State Police foreign
make sure your red light is on when
you're talking pretty good uh good
afternoon my name is Frank Campo
um I've been employed with the state
police for over 18 years and I am here
representing the Troopers Association
my life was not
good afternoon my name is Kathy Stacy
I'm the Rockingham County Register of
Deeds I am in the New Hampshire
retirement system I've had held this
position for the past 30 years but I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties I am the
legislative chair and their vice
president thank you
state representative Matt Wilhelm from
Manchester represent words uh 1 3 10 11
and 12 in service the house Democratic
leader
I'm representative Sherman Packard I'm
the speaker of the house and I'm from
Londonderry
I'm Donna soucy
we're representing five Wards in the
city of Manchester in the town of
Litchfield I have served a number of
terms on the Edna committee and uh have
been engaged in retirement issues for a
number of years as well thank you
and I'm Jim Gray I'm the president pro
tem of the Senate chair of the Senate
Finance chair of election law
I'm also the Senate to representative to
University system uh Board of Trustees
I'm also a city councilman in the city
of Rochester uh have been for about 10
years or I guess a little more now
represented in Senate
thank you Senator
um uh my name is Sharon Carson I
represent Senate District 14. I am not
an assigned uh full member of this
commission I am an alternate and I am
sitting in today for Senator Bradley who
was not able to be here I currently
serve as the Senate Majority Leader and
I am also the chair of Senate Judiciary
I'm also the vice chair of Edna after
serving many many years as the chair of
Senate Edna as well
Senator David Waters District 4.
hi I'm Dan representative Dan McGuire
but I'm here representing or
substituting for my wife Carol McGuire
she finally got a periodontist
appointment after two months of waiting
so she couldn't give it up
um so I'll tell you about her so Carol
is the chair of
um the house Edna committee she's in her
15th term in the 15th year in the house
eighth term and she's also the current
chair of the gel car committee
hi my name is Peter leishman and I'm a
member of the New Hampshire house
good afternoon I'm Dave Karen the Town
Administrator and dairy I've been
managing New Hampshire municipalities
for the last 42 years and I'm
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
good afternoon Brian rill I'm the
president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire
representing approximately 2000 active
and retired professional firefighters
throughout the state and I'm also a fire
captain for the city of Portsmouth
good afternoon my name is Robert Fuller
I am a teacher in Manchester and I'm
representing the teachers
my name is Dwayne Ford I'm the business
administrator for the bow and Dunbar and
school districts and representing the
New Hampshire school boards Association
all right thank you we'll go back to you
and let you reintroduce yourself with
the Micron this time sure thank you my
name is romano Martins I am a
representative from
uh the same employee Association uh I'm
a long time resident of the State of New
Hampshire I work at the Department of
Health and service 35 years plus I'm not
here representing the Department of
Health and service for through full
transparency I'm also a trustee at the
retirement system I'm not representative
retirement system not the budget
Committee in Hooksett where I'm also a
member of the budget committee uh I
thank everybody for being here and uh
and I will thank you
okay thank you next order of business is
the election of the chair do I have
nominations Senator Carson thank you
thank you Mr uh Mr chair um I would like
to nominate Senator gray to be the
chairperson of the commission
and Senator gray accepts a nomination
further nomination I think he had his
enough for us
real like to nominate representative
Carol McGuire
great
um
I'd like to second that nomination
Mr chair if I make yes ma'am thank you I
have a concern because representative
McGuire is not present here today
um so
um do you want to know if she would
accept I I
don't
think anybody should
or her other than herself because
there's going to be a lot of work
involved in this commission and I would
rather have her be here to accept the
nomination than somebody else
so I I just questioned that I don't
think that's good procedure thank you
it's true I would be willing to withdraw
my nomination
Mr chair I'd like to be a black lives
yeah I would really like the commission
to reconsider that uh because in the
past we have been able to nominate
somebody who are not attending the other
thing is we heard from the
representative that she has a special
appointment other than that this is not
something that would preclude her from
being here
historically she had been very active
and attentive to all her commission and
all the work that she did in the
legislature and I think we should
consider her nomination and support that
thank you
uh you're free to make the nomination
yourself and see if someone second said
I do nominate uh representative Carl
magaya to be the chair of this
Commission
ERS Daryl second it Mr chairman thank
you
okay
any other nominations
okay we have two candidates all those in
favor of Jim Gray saying raise your hand
one two three four five if I got it
right
all right all those in favor Carol
McGuire say I I'll raise your hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine I think
Carol is the chair
um and now we're at a quandary
he's now the chair we don't have a chair
and um can I nominate I'll make like to
make a motion can't do anything
I'll certainly I just speak I'd like to
nominate uh Senator gray as the vice
chairman
second second
um I don't know who's running the
meeting at this point because my duties
ended with the election of the chair
that that's my problem you know
parliamentarily may I be recognized
I can't recognize you I'm not the chair
anymore we do have a representative
who's standing for representative
McGuire right there
I'm I'm sorry I you know again you know
the statute says that the first order of
business is to elect a chair
okay you have elected a chair
okay therefore my duties as the caller
of this meeting ended with that election
so
we're without a chair right now
I respectfully disagree
Senator thank you Mr chairman this is
why I brought up the issue
um you can't you were the first name
Senator your job was to set the meeting
and get a chair elected this body
decided to elect a chair the chair is
not here and we cannot continue with any
business until the chair is here
that includes the rest of the agenda
that includes electing a vice chair that
includes electing a clerk we can't hear
from the retirement system the chair is
in charge and this is the problem
we're adjourned
thank you